c'est l'événement de cette rentrée
littéraire le premier roman du
Marseillais Youssef Salem Youssef salam
c'est moi c'est de l'autobiographe
absolument tout inventé j'ai vraiment
pas envie que les gens confondent et qui
s'imaginent que c'est l'histoire de ma
de ma famille
[Musique]
qui organise sa vie en fonction de son
père à 45 ans tu sais quoi elle est
tournée générale pour tout le monde
soyez que vous étiez fauché mais j'ai
une ardoise ici demain je vois mes
parents donc je me bourre la gueule
vous savez ce que disait Philippe à
propos de la famille si tu es cet
écrivain qui disait quand un écrivain né
dans une famille la famille est foutue
foutue
vous voulez bien me faire une avance
pour le TGV et tout ça et puis c'est
l'anniversaire de ma mère le monde de
l'édition c'est la catastrophe je peux
pas je peux éventuellement vous faire
des avances mais pas une je comprends
pas vous pouvez me faire plusieurs
avances c'était une blague
maintenant on va se tutoyer
je vais te présenter tout le monde tu
bois pas il y a un jour il faut pas que
tu bosses c'est aujourd'hui c'est ce
soir ok ils vont tous scruter ils vont
filmer avec leur téléphone portable
c'est pas le moment de dire des
conneries c'est pas le moment d'en faire
[Musique]
j'ai quelque chose à vous dire je suis
grand-père non maman mon livre a été
publié
toutes les fautes que tu n'as pas manqué
de connaître je sais j'ai complètement
oublié de te le faire relire cette André
malade de voir toutes les fautes que
j'ai laissé dedans s'il te plaît ne le
lis pas même s'il est présélectionné
pour le Goncourt le prix Goncourt oui le
concours
c'est bien la France
[Musique]
du sexe
encore les grosses encore les gros
[Musique]